pour démarrer les agriculteurs repassent
à l'offensive sur le dossier du
glyphosate un moment bien choisi Florent
la justice à tranché elle vient de
déboutter les 5600 pisseurs de
glyphosate qui avaient déposé plainte
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autruie
Noben pour la FNSEA centre valde Loire
alors que l'Europe doit de nouveau se
prononcer sur la prolongation du
pesticide controversé Lucas Chopin avec
lesat turquy la FNSEA contre-attaque le
syndicat agricole fait front contre le
test urinaire effectué par plusieurs
milliers de Français en cause les
potentiels faux positifs qui révèlent la
présence de glyphosate dans le corps des
personnes testées l'occasion donc
d'essayer de redorer le blason de cette
substance herbicide controversée nous
notre notre combat c'est de connaître la
réalité c'est dire que s'il y avait eu
un vrai problème on en aurait tenu
compte et on aurait dit ben faut faut
prendre les mesures qui s'adaptent là
aujourd'hui le le parquet de de le pôle
santé du parquet de Paris a pris une
position et les conclusions é ont été
très clair c'està-dire de dire bah il y
a aucun problème les plaintes ne sont
pas recevables pour la FNSEA les tests
employés ne seraient pas adaptés aux
analyses d'urine et profiterait
notamment au laboratoire allemand qui
les produit une opération qui
desservirait selon eux les agriculteurs
français qui utilisent le glyphosate si
le glyphosate disparaît monzonauillère
son taponne le coquillard si ça arrête
c'est pas les firmes c'est les
agriculteurs parce que ça va avoir un
coût supérieur de production et il faut
résister à la concurrence internationale
sans prolongation l'autorisation du
glyphosate expirera le 15 décembre
prochain pour rappel en 2015 l'OMS a
classé cette substance comme cancérogène
probable